Just before we get started,
I'd like to give a quick plug for a new
channel that I've started at school
biographics where we look at biographies
of famous people from history as well as
the present day.
It's not all politics or that we have
done some politics.
We've looked at Vladimir Putin as well
as almost swartz and I got.
I know he definitely covers both fields,
but please do check it out.
There is a link in the description below
our,
I'd say you probably know pieces of
field build companies and I support
people who are building new things.
He was one of the founders of paypal,
the first investor in facebook,
and he's one of the most important
technology and venture capital Gurus in
the world.
He's obviously a multibillionaire.
That is also a bit of a peculiar guy.
For instance,
he financed projects like the Sea
Standing Institute in organization aimed
at being a politically autonomous
floating city and is also funded anti
aging research by using the blood of
young people.
These are the thiel is also known for
being the biggest supporter of Donald
Trump in silicon valley.
Although in some conversations with
journalists recently,
he's already shown some concerns.
I mean,
what the hell all of us have the right
to be wrong sometimes.
The thing is this,
in 2011 Peter Thiel was granted New
Zealand citizenship and told his
application.
He said this,
I'm happy to say categorically that I've
found no other country that aligns more
with my view of the future,
the New Zealand.
The truth is that this is probably no
surprise to you,
regular viewers,
a visual politic.
We've already said into other videos how
much we love this country and not just
for its beauty.
Although New Zealand is one of the most
beautiful countries in the world.
There are also an example to be followed
to take a look at these statements.
All former prime minister billing about
his predecessor.
Occasionally John would come home and
complain that he was the only one who
didn't have a jet and how his colleagues
were horrified to find that he as a
world leader had to travel on commercial
aircraft,
but I assured him that it was character
building and kept them in touch with
normal people.
Bill English,
no New Zealand doesn't have an air force
one of their own,
but it is one of the easiest countries
to do business in and as we've already
seen,
it's one of the most prosperous,
least corrupt and safest countries on
the
planets.
Unless onto that,
they're first rate public services.
Their ranking is one of the countries
with the highest standards of living as
well as having one of the lowest
employment rates.
Just take a look at this chart.
They weren't always like this.
The Sun didn't always ride.
There's no doubt that New Zealand is a
top rate country,
but things weren't always like that.
I'm definitely not.
Not at all.
In fact,
what we are going to see now is a real
story.
The story of the country that was
determined to learn from its mistakes,
to transform everything didn't work,
and by doing so become an international
role.
Well,
this is definitely not the norm.
Placing people first before any kind of
ideology and the electorial interests.
It's not so common,
at least not in most countries,
but let's see what happens.
Well,
the first thing we have to say is that
New Zealand was always a relatively
wealthy country.
In fact,
by the late 19 fifties,
this country had the third highest per
capita income in the world,
which is certainly not bad,
right?
Just wait a moment because that's the
moment when things started to get a bit
worse,
bad enough.
In fact,
the by 1984,
the per capita income was similar to
that of Portugal or Turkey.
So.
Well now you're probably wondering,
well what happens,
but New Zealand's to drop so far.
Well,
it could be said that the government,
they went a bit too far.
By that time,
the government of New Zealand had
meddled with the economy to such an
extent that it's hard to even imagine
what it was like.
There were many,
many taxes.
Most of them incredibly complex and most
of them really,
really high.
Just so you can get an idea of that.
The highest income tax rate was almost
70 percent and the lowest was still 40
percent and companies,
well,
they didn't get any better treatments.
The profit tax was 48 percent,
which is twice as much as the world's
average nowadays,
and on top of all of that,
there were tons of regulations.
There were price controls for almost any
product,
currency controls,
and that's just scratching the surface
as an example.
Any import require the approval of the
administration and it was really hard
for New Zealanders to invest their money
outside of the country.
We have foreign exchange controls.
That meant I couldn't buy a subscription
to the Economist magazine without the
permission of the Minister of Finance,
Maurice,
p mcteague,
former minister of the government of New
Zealand.
Look the controls and regulations.
They didn't just establish a minimum
wages.
They also set caps for the maximum.
Yep.
You heard that?
Absolutely right.
But let's say that a business owner
wanted to pay a bonus to his workers.
Well,
that wasn't an easy task
ask
and as you can imagine,
the state owned and controlled almost
every large national company,
media,
airlines,
insurance companies,
banks,
even hotels.
Yet the government was really managing
hotels.
Not Joking here.
So in other words,
the early 19 eighties,
New Zealand was the very example of
extreme statism in one way or another.
Almost everything was controlled by
bureaucrats and politicians and so well,
what were the consequences of all this?
They weren't exactly positive,
right.
After 23 years of deficits and the
government's balance public debt has
absolutely skyrocketed.
It was to figure unemployment's private
investors were pulling out of the
country and the Kiwi youth,
while they were fleeing in huge numbers
by that time doing business in New
Zealand,
it was an enormously complicated
process.
And to be honest,
it was only attempted by the bravest.
Everything started to change in 1984
when elections took place.
Plan to move forward
in 1984 in the midst of a tough crisis,
elections were celebrated.
The winner was David longer you have the
center left party.
This nation is at risk is how basic it
is.
The new government,
they had a purpose to overcome the
crisis and still change the national
model.
They are to replace everything that
didn't work and to make sure they did it
without leaving anybody behind.
While at the same time granting the
opportunities for others to move
forward.
So even though David [inaudible] was the
prime minister,
the leader of this whole process was the
minister of Finance and that was sent
Roger Douglas.
In fact,
the process is named after him.
It's known as Roger Nomix.
We went probably from being the most
regulated,
uh,
in the developed world to the least
Reagan a regulator.
We actually discussed this in a previous
video where we talked about the
agricultural reforms that have been so
successful in New Zealand is Roger
Douglas started and ambitious reform
program known as Rajan Nanex in this
program that many areas of the economy
were liberalized and this included the
primary sector and these changes took
place almost overnight.
Price controls were eliminated and most
farming subsidies were removed.
But Roger Nomix,
it wasn't just about agriculture.
The plan affected almost every aspect of
the state and created a new political
culture.
In fact,
by the time the rights international
party won the elections in 1990 and took
power again,
everything had changed.
And the new government followed the
labor process.
Roger Nomix.
It was a political philosophy that
radically changed the country between
the year 1984 and the beginnings of the
21st century.
The first thing that the government did
was declared a war on bureaucracy.
They did it in three ways.
First,
they did a thorough analysis of every
governmental departments.
If what they did was not essential or
could be better done by the market as
well.
That was the end of it.
Following the same pattern.
They started an ambitious plan of
privatization.
I mean,
think about it.
What was the state doing?
Wasting time managing hotels,
airlines or telecommunications,
thanks to competition.
The market could do a much better job
hands with less cost and more
innovation.
Pie Come at it from an angle of what's
good for the consumer.
Uh,
the provider.
I don't care a fundamentally who the
provider might be a might be a public
institution,
a private institution,
so long as it serves the consumer or the
taxpayer.
That's where I come from.
Seconds of the 35 remaining public
agencies,
the government made management work
under market conditions.
This was the case for air traffic
controllers for instance.
And the results,
they were totally terrific.
Not so neat.
Did the services of these public
agencies improve?
They went from costing the government a
billion dollars every year to generating
with taxes and profits more than a
billion dollars.
This is money that could then be put
into things like education,
health care and culture.
But that wasn't the end of it.
Since regulations and laws were numerous
and complex,
the government decided to work towards
an important goal and that was the
simplification and elimination of any
laws that they deemed unnecessary.
And so what was the result of all of
these changes when you started this
process with the Department of
Transportation?
It had 5,600
employees.
When we finished it had 53.
When we started with the forest service,
it had 17,000
employees.
When we finished it had 17.
Maurice p mcteague ends unemployment's.
It didn't increase.
It was reduced.
So there's this very illustrative story
and it actually involves deer as in the
animals.
So when the British arrived in New
Zealand,
the country doesn't have any large
animals.
So the wealthy families,
they imported deer for hunting as well.
Can you guess what happens these days?
They spread rapidly,
forming the massive herds that ghost
critical ecological damage by
overgrazing thought 120 years.
The state had spent a lot of money
trying to think this plague in order to
preserve the local ecosystem.
Well,
one day they came up with a new idea.
Why couldn't they let farmers hunt and
raised the deer fence?
Well,
that's exactly what they did.
Not saying that you did this,
put an end to the plague.
New Zealand today is the world's largest
supplier of deer meat and all of this.
It really does make sense and it's also
interesting to see what happened to
taxes which were simplified in Regina.
Many were surprised by the results.
Tax Collection actually increased by 20
percent.
The subsidization.
It was cost not only in agriculture but
also in industry sectors,
but there was much more than just
economic reform here,
the reforms that reached the public
services and take a look at what happens
with education.
For instance,
the education budget of New Zealand.
It hadn't stopped growing for years,
but the results,
they were just getting worse and worse.
So the question was,
well,
a we students getting more stupid and
that didn't really seem likely so when
the government analyze the causes,
they realize this,
an important share of the budget was not
actually being spent on education,
but on administration.
These were quality evaluation agencies,
rating firms,
dossie agencies and so on.
So what did the government decide to do?
Well,
they simply removed it all and they gave
the schools control with a management
board chosen by the parents.
Also,
they allow parents to choose schools
freely,
private or public,
and the government would pay for it.
And well,
what we can tell you now is that
education results improved significantly
as well.
The same thing,
it happens with everything else.
New Zealand today,
it's a prosperous country with a very
high standard of living and to use
public services,
education,
health and culture are among the best in
the world.
So that leaves us thinking that museum,
that it's an amazing example for
countries in Latin America or some
European countries like Spain,
Italy,
Greece,
and Portugal.
Well,
if anything is for certain,
is that the lands of Kiwis is a great
country.
And now it's your turn.
Do you think that New Zealand makes a
good model to be followed?
Well,
please do leave your onset in the
comments below.
We'd love to hear from you and also in
this survey.
I also really hope you enjoyed this
video.
Please hit like if you did and do not
forget to subscribe to our channel for
brand new videos.
Every Monday and Thursday we'll say,
please do go check out my new channel
that's called biographics.
We also do videos on Mondays and
Thursdays are great days for Youtube.
It's biographies of people from history.
Link in the description below,
and as always,
thank you for awhile.